Oh guys all right everyone can actually
hear me it sounds like
that was that was gone
as and that is his last name is actually
that bias that you guys are all thinking
I I kid you not his related to that bias
he is also known as the guy who signed
the check all right so well welcome to
our Facebook help sorry
welcome to facebook welcome to pilot at
facebook i hope you guys will enjoy the
the next two days i know there were a
lot of interesting things going on
yesterday and today i want to kick it
off with talking about why I think
python apart on is pretty good when
working with data at any scale really
you know we talk about big data or small
data all kinds of different scales and
we'll kind of see what it is that we can
do with Python hopefully through a story
actually I like to tell stories so in
this particular case I'm just going to
set it up so that which I'll go out to
start up pretty new startup you're the
CEO you're trying to implement a bunch
of new stuff and you know the CEO is
actually going after going after
different kind of clients and the task
at hand is implementing a machine
learning system to do something all
right we're not going to go into the
details of what you're going to do with
it we'll just focus on how you're going
to actually implement it and how
partisan can help and the goal is really
to get acquired by a publicly traded
social networking company for an
undisclosed but sizable amount and I
should also say obviously you guys can
see the disclaimer but after i put the
disclaimer there i kind of felt bad
because it's not true i do have direct
influence over acquisition decisions of
my wife kinda all right and of course
the answer is use Python to get their
wine and I'll talk a little bit about
the why part and why Python can actually
help you in that particular setup and
there are five reasons we're going to
talk about five reasons and we we I kind
of sorted them in the order that you
might need as you progress in your
startup at first or now you know you
want to get results very quickly you
need lots of functionality later on you
might need to speak C++ I like C++ you
guys will figure that out and then
eventually you will need domain-specific
languages and you know you can't do it
all by yourself you need people all
right so you want to get the results are
quickly let's talk about dialogue
there's an elephant in the room right i
mean this is a and whenever we are
talking about getting to results very
quickly there is indeed
elephant in the room that we need to
address and that's the fact that two
8020 rule is alive and kicking in fact
data preparation is still the most
time-consuming part of whole thing so
when we talk to about getting results
quickly we're actually we actually have
to take into account today to prep part
in fact I'm pretty sure if by this time
you haven't seen this tweet they take
your data scientists license back this
was I believe posted last year and at
strada about a year ago and you know
it's kind of funny but it's also kind of
true right all right so let's talk about
how Python can actually help you in this
particular case now here here I'm
actually setting up a very simple data
frame we're just going to play with toy
examples in this case in this particular
case I have gender data height and
weight let's say you're a biomedical
startup or something like that and very
typical of real life data you have
missing data as well and when you're
actually doing a lot of competitions or
when you're looking at books missing
data is not really dealt with a lot but
this is our toy data set and if you
actually wanted to process this in
Python super easy you don't have to know
or you don't have to understand a lot of
the details of the corner cases and
things like that you just need to know
the basics of it and then you can
actually use pandas itself which
provides you with a lot of different
methodologies and scikit-learn one of
our favorite tool kits around here to do
a standard normal asian to do label
encoding to do label urbanization and
all other goodies and eventually you can
grow up on two pandas and again do
merges and all other kind of stuff on
your data frames on your data tables the
interesting thing here is these are not
really that hard algorithms not that
hard but there are all these little toy
in the corner cases so it's already
taken care of for you and Python can
actually help you I get there fast and
from that data sets shown in the label
number one we go to label number two
missing it interpolated everything
normalized everything binarized and we
are good to go in just about 15 lines of
code
we do this every day here at Facebook
this kind of stuff all right so they do
prep is done but you know machine
learning still requires a lot of
machinery hands machine learning plus
there's that little secret of data
science folks that everyone kind of
knows but no one really talks about it
very very explicitly and that is the
fact that big data actually means you
either sample you distribute your
computation or you stream data there is
no other way really this one I stole
from our Jason is going to talk later on
today big data really means your memory
is small that's really like about Big
Data mean means and the smaller memory
you have the smaller the data can get
and you will still consider that a big
data so when you're actually dealing
with a setup like this where your data
simply does not fit into memory what do
you do you device you do eyes
architectures like this and the first
time you actually see this it might look
a little bit scary right there's a bunch
of batch operations mini batch
operations going on there are a few CPUs
they're a bunch of different machines
then you aggregate that your classic
leaf aggregator kind of an architecture
just passing down the results of
whatever algorithm you're running either
a machine learning algorithm or some
other data algorithm that you're running
and it looks it looks kind of scary
that's that's the reality of it so let's
see actually how we can do this with
Python relatively easily it turns out so
this is the Amazon movies data set from
Stanford snap data set group I guess or
collection of data sets it's basically
movie reviews and then their
corresponding writing that are given by
different people and Orion is actually
going to talk about this kind of setup
for sentiment analysis later on today
and and he will mention how we how we do
that for on facebook data but i'll focus
on the amazon movie review stuff so it's
nine jig about of theta it's really not
that much but it still requires
especially if you're going to run it on
a 4g gabite
mcintosh laptop kind of a thing still
requires some manipulation so here's
what i did i used scikit-learn again
hashing with riser if you don't know the
hashing trick learn it it basically just
takes all your reviews the text
vectorize the whole thing using the
hashing trick so that you don't actually
use a lot of memory HDD classifier from
scikit-learn again using the partial fit
method which allows you to actually
mini-batch everything and job live which
comes with scikit-learn itself just dump
all your all your models that you
calculated on individual CPUs at the
machine level you're essentially just
copying those models back to the
aggregated and at the very end you're
loading them up and you're just taking
their average that's it that technique
by the way is is a pretty cool pretty
interesting one and obviously you can't
get very complicated here you can
actually do feedback loops and all that
kind of stuff I'm not really going into
the details of that of all those
advanced things that you can do to
improve your results or to get to more
mathematically correct methodologies but
this as is is actually pretty standard
you can do this in scikit-learn today
and if you're interested in learning
about more about that last part there
was actually an excellent talk last year
at PI data silicon valley by olivier i
don't think he's here today just check
that one out you can actually learn all
about the details of how to do that
linear averaging so the interesting
thing here is that thing I actually just
wanted to test myself so I was able to
implement the whole thing in four hours
Python nothing else well ok there's
glass Dreyfus over there we already had
some infrastructure but other than that
right it's pretty cool the fact that you
can actually do this and you're able to
suddenly process gigabytes and gigabytes
of data in just a few hours actually is
a testament to power of Python but I'm
preaching to the choir and it's not
really the point here but I just used
the default settings and so pretty good
precision and recall in that movie
review test all right so the the moral
of the story here is if you really know
your libraries in and out libraries like
panda
which I've been using it for a few years
now I don't think I know all the methods
that it has its really really very rich
or socket learn that surprised me every
day or any other library that are in the
PI data space that you get to use if you
know them you can get the results very
quickly in just a few Miller of hours
you can actually process the same amount
of data that we process here at Facebook
so that brings me to my second point you
will need lots of functionality there
will be those little things like I was
talking about the whole glass surface
thingy and you know that's that's
essentially the kind of functionality
that you will need and you'll need lots
of it for doing different kind of things
and python has for a very long time
known as batteries included language
right this if you ask me changing a
little bit i want to say rather than
batteries included it's probably
batteries easily available and the
reason why i say that is even though we
have 200 plus modules in standard Python
and some of them are kind of outdated
but we have about 40,000 modules on on
pi PI we have about 300,000 repos on get
up that you can actually use to do all
kinds of interesting things here here
are a bunch of libraries that we use
around here these are all the usual
suspects that you probably use in LA and
we use them for different reasons
sometimes for experimentation and as
you'll hear during the rest of the day
sometimes for actually doing production
work but this is not all there's a lot
more obviously and I want to kind of
talk about what else is out there
especially coming from facebook right so
here is one this is an open source on
get up and if you're a facebook
employees sitting there and if you don't
recognize the name come find me i'll
tell you what the internal name for this
open-source project is this is a pie if
you wanted to implement python-based
data services in just a few dozen of a
dozen lines there you go this will
actually take care of it using trip as
its basis and we use this a lot every
day in some of the things that we do
here at Facebook cloud it's an talked
about this yesterday it's a recently
open source library from
facebook that allows you to do very
sophisticated online experiments and
again all written in Python well here's
something that's not written in Python
press stop distributed SQL but it
actually is blazing fast and super easy
to integrate with Python because it
provides you with an HTTP API if you're
dealing with big data I have to say you
have to give presta try it's really
pretty good it's one of the best that I
that I had the pleasure of working on it
makes that so much easier and if you
don't want to deal with the HTTP API
yourself well here's an API from Dropbox
that will actually speak to hive and
press to all at the same time using
standard Python libraries that makes
life easy for you set up your personal
cluster and you can actually very very
easily go and run things using Python to
get your data here's another here's
another data store that I'm a big fan of
rocks TB this was built on top of label
DB which is from google which kind of is
the local version of big table that's a
long chain of interns inheritances over
there and it actually is really pretty
cool if you're operating on flash and
all that kind of stuff and again easily
accessible from Python using something
called site on if you haven't heard of
it I'm going to talk about sites on
later on and finally one of my favorite
library is it actually happens to be the
fourth popular library on github
Facebook's tornado to actually serve
different kinds of web pages and when I
show this people are well that's not
really a data thing well Jason can tell
you how we're actually using tornado for
all kinds of very cool visualizations
and data services all right so how do we
use these things I'm just going to talk
about a few examples and then you'll
actually hear it from the other guys
later on throughout today so here's the
the it's not a tool this is not a
product I don't know what to call it the
physical object that we call insights
wall and if you guys haven't seen this
yesterday if this is your first day
attending or if you haven't actually
went to building 15 today go check it
out next to building
an extra son of ping-pong which is where
the other talks other sessions are going
to be taking care of today there is this
giant wall that is actually a touch
screen that allows you to play with
facebook data and if you don't believe
me that's actually a person right there
touching the screen all backed by Python
infrastructure it uses trifft it uses
data swarm it uses Bristow using its
Python connector 100% a Python back-end
actually supplying the data into this
thing and you guys can go and play with
it today or as available today that's
all right so here's another thing that
you guys probably seen before I don't
know I think Paul Paul is here or at
least I was told that he was here
yesterday this is the famous picture
from Paul Butler I think it was a year
2010 original i believe was implemented
in our and I'm Paul later on I came up
with a python implementation and that
thing over there which is currently Mark
Zuckerberg cover photo and used in many
other places such as our internet
organizations and things like that
actually rendered by Python now granted
and the data comes from data swarm which
mike will talk about i granted we took
the original code and modified it a
little bit there's a lot of data in
there so it was taking a very very long
time to render the whole thing but we
didn't need to go anywhere else we still
used python using pythons
multiprocessing and features modules we
were actually able to paralyze the
rendering on to 32 cpus and take care of
the whole thing in less than 10 minutes
and that's the what you're seeing here
as I said these are two very simple
examples will actually talk you'll
actually get to hear a lot more today
about the kind of things that we do
using Python a ton well I said today
I'll I they can actually talk about plan
out yesterday I know it was a
well-attended session so hopefully you
guys enjoyed it Jason is going to talk
about how we actually bring all these
technologies for data visualization
later on near sign of ping-pong and
building 15 Ryan is going to talk about
sentiment classification
amazon movie reviews thingy that i
mentioned well this one is the facebook
version of that using our very own well
not our but Python community is very own
scikit-learn and finally a mic is going
to talk about data swarm and I don't
think actually that tagline is on the on
the program so I think we should talk
about that a little bit data storm
should really be you know subtitled how
to move 300 petabytes around and you can
you can actually listen to my ex talk
about how we do that alright so the
model of the story here is funeral
pythons right rich ecosystem you can
actually have lots of functionality you
don't need to go elsewhere Python
provides you with a lot of hooks and
functionality that will allow you to do
that machine learning task that we set
up all the way at the beginning oh all
right every you know it's it's all nice
but eventually you might you might
actually need to speak C++ and if you're
using a lot of the numerical libraries
today you are kind of speaking C or C++
without knowing that's because the the
need for speed happens we sometimes we
actually want to run things really
really fast and the fact of the matter
is C C++ has a lot of established
libraries that we can use and that you
can actually tweak to your liking so it
can be useful we like Python but C++ can
be useful can be powerful all right at
this point I should actually also
probably open a parenthesis and tell you
why I like C++ so much so this book I
think it's probably all around 10 years
now modern C++ design written by
Facebook's very own andreia let's come
to school is probably first book when i
first started understanding how powerful
C++ can be right now granted Andre since
then actually moved on and he actually
works on the D language now and I will
cynic in a little bit of advertisement
there's going to be a d conference at
the end of this month again on facebook
campus it's just so that android doesn't
get mad at me for mentioning his old
days all right with that will close the
parenthesis and continue so I said C++
can be useful and the thing the fact of
the matter is it's actually super easy
to call c and c++ code
from Python now there's the good old
standard ctypes if you've never seen it
there you go that example is complete
with the exception of the compile step I
have that little see a file up there
labeled by label number one now say add
all those functions and by using the C
types module that comes with Python you
can actually very easily call this code
from your Python library cool there's
also other stuff like boost Python vivre
which can be very powerful also might
want to you know make you cry swig which
is also quite powerful and complicated
but my favorite as I mentioned at the
beginning is actually site on now if
you'll never work with site on if you
never use site on give it a look it's
pretty cool in that in this particular
example i'm actually not showing you how
to call a C or C++ code from sites on
but this the PI X file that you're
seeing will compile into C++ by sector
and it requires a little bit of a setup
which is shown in in label number two
and eventually you can actually call it
just like any other library from your
Python code and it's all nice and nice
and dandy and you know Satan is actually
pretty powerful it's used by a lot of
different libraries type I uses it
pandas uses its scikit-learn uses it of
other libraries also use it the rocks DB
driver that I was talking about it's
actually written insights on very very
useful library but it introduces
complexity to builds and when I'm
talking to python guys when I mentioned
this they go what are you talking about
building Python what what does that mean
and you know the reality of the matter
is yeah you can actually build Python
and here's our little secret it's
actually even easier to call c and c++
from python if you're working for
facebook and you can get a little bit of
taste of that today here's an open
source library that we open source i
think about a year ago called buck it's
mainly used in the outside world for
building Android applications but it
actually has rudimentary Python support
and you can go to their group and and
read about how that part works it looks
something like that the Python binary
you give it a name and then you tell
what sources to include and there are
some dependencies that you can actually
mention today in the outside world
Python supporting bak exist and you can
use it we use a very similar system
internally and we actually have site on
support internally which essentially
means instead of helloworld dot pie if i
change that to hello world pi x all that
set up step that's normally required by
sight own is taking care for me so that
actually empowers people a lot that
allows us to do a lot of interesting
things and then you know you don't you
don't need to restrict yourself with bug
there is another one from Twitter that
will allow you to do similar things I
don't think it actually has direct sight
on support but i believe it's relatively
straightforward to add that it also
comes with something called a text file
which is a python binary similar to what
i showed before and many other companies
also have similar tools that build tools
that you can use there is a user auto
abuse benefit to this that a lot of the
times when you're actually getting your
hands dirty with data and you're about
to implant the machine learning system
nature language processing system or
something like that that's not
immediately obvious because you're very
focused on trying to get that and that
auto abuse benefit is the fact that this
kind of build system takes care of
dependency management and dependency
management is not nice Ryan you don't
wanna you don't want to deal with that
even with Pip and virtual end it's it
can actually be hard especially if
you're using libraries like a numpy site
by now friends of continuum have this
awesome environment that actually makes
that life easy but if you're running
this stuff on your own hardware
sometimes you need to compile it
yourself and in that particular case a
build system like the ones that I'm
talking about will make your life really
really easy and they're out there
they're available and you can actually
use them today to basically give
yourself an edge in terms of being able
to run your Python code on any machine
that you desire without setting it up
head of time check it out those parts
and wineries are pretty powerful so the
moral of the story here is yeah pippin
virtual and were nice but if you're
linking to any and unpaid son code get a
build system and you will actually be
quite happy with the results I promise
all right sort of my favorite topics the
the domain-specific language stuff it's
also sometimes not very obvious why this
is actually important for data science
he thinks so here's the here's the
here's the story right that's Tower of
Babel I believe the story is is is the
before there was one language and then
after their multiple languages and
there's a reason why we have so many
languages all right because people's
cultures are different people actually
need to talk about different kind of
things and that's why we have so many
languages in humans computers are no
different code has to scale not only by
a number of users our x amount of data
but also by a number of employees you
have in their startup now we were we
started at day 42 and you only had two
employees but that's going to grow all
right if you're going to get acquired
but by that social networking company
you're going to have a lot more people
20 or 50 and in that particular case the
number of employees as they go up it
becomes important that people understand
each other not by the language english
or whatever other language they're
speaking but also with the computer
language that they use and
domain-specific languages can actually
help you a lot in that particular case
they are especially very effective when
it comes to you know when you your you
reach critical mass of a few hundred
people all right so why do we use Python
for inside facebook we use it to define
services for our internal cloud we use
it to distribute configurations to data
centers we use it for data etl pipelines
this is data swarm that Mike is gonna
where's mike mike is going to talk about
and there are many many other examples
it works really really well for that
kind of stuff so here's one example from
data swarm so that you guys understand
what I'm talking about when I say dsl
the label number one hive to file
operator you don't
need to actually know what this language
is doing you can immediately see that
well okay it's probably getting some
data from hive and putting it into file
it's very very obvious it gives their
name export on use pages in this
particular case and then it defines
something called the PHP operator
clearly it's going to do some kind of
PHP functionality on here and that
particular operator actually depends on
the previous operator that we defined
that's a DSL right there and as you can
tell it's it looks like Python in fact
it is Python and it will execute
anything else that you might want to
have in your Python code but it works
pretty well in this case entity and it's
hard it's essentially just defining a
dependency graph as I said magaziner
talk a lot more about this but that's
what it does it's a specialized language
to define a dependency grab that allows
you to move a data around and when I say
data I mean 300 petabytes of data around
very very easily by actually chopping it
out down into these small pieces and
that has a lot of benefits to it simply
because everyone understands the
commonalities of the language so they
know how to read those files not
everyone comes up with their own little
tiny different way of moving this data
around all right so there's a there's a
technique that I like a lot this is not
how data swarm is implemented for about
this technique that I like a lot and I
think it shows the power of Python when
you're dealing with domain-specific
languages so I'll talk that about that a
little bit buyer if you're familiar with
this meme since I was using all historic
pay you know pictures before i figured
i'll pick this clown instead of the one
that you normally see all right so let's
say that you are trying to come up with
a language called my cool script all
right and the extension very fittingly
will be mcs and you want to be able to
run this thing by running something
called ron mcs pi you pass the file name
and then you get some results that's the
goal and let's say that in this
particular case what we want to have in
our MCS file is that simple expression y
equals 2 times the list of
two and three and you're setting the
answer to why and that's how it gets
printed to screen now if you try to use
the parts on interpreter that's what
you're going to get what's shown in
label number two all right Python will
actually interpret that as replicate
this list and it will actually do one
two three one two three but that's not
what you want what you really want is as
if all these arrays are non pyar raised
so that you can actually describe a very
complicated model for example or you
know a machine learning model or a time
series model or something else that
you're developing this this dsl for
that's what you want you want what's
happening in number three but Python
does not give you by default well it
turns out you can actually get there
very very easily if you're not familiar
with AST module abstract syntax trees
they are perfect for domain-specific
languages they will actually allow you
to do really interesting really crazy
things with Python language without
getting out of the Python interpreter
itself we'll talk a little bit about
this part what's this actually happening
here is you read a file your MGS Michael
script file you send it to the HT module
for parsing and then you run a visitor a
transformer not transformer on it and
I'll show what that does and you get
your results that way so essentially
what's happening here is every time
Python sees that particular expression 2
times 1 2 3 it actually hands you that
that structure that you see on screen so
binary operator there's a left there's
the operator there's the right part and
that's actually what part 1 gives you a
true the AST module and this is exactly
what python itself uses to actually
implement the thing and since this is
just another python structure you can
actually run this particular code and it
looks a little bit complicated i will
very briefly explain what it does and
get to the result that we wanted to get
this essentially visits every expression
in your python script in your cool
script excuse me and whenever it sees a
number and a list it will automatically
wrap it with an umpire array you don't
need to do anything
the interpreter will actually take care
of this and the last the red function is
actually where how we're setting the
answer and you can see it's implemented
very very simply the interesting thing
here is if you take this piece of code
which is what 15 lines and combine it
with this piece of code which is not
much this is a complete program and I
think I'm missing the import statements
but other than that everything else is
on those two screens and if you run this
thing it will actually start
implementing your domain specific
language in the way that that that I
just described and that can actually be
developed into very very complicated
domain-specific languages that allows
you to do pretty cool things with you
know data science the topics so what are
the advantages first of all I think
everyone agrees here that python is a
pretty beautiful language I mean I
personally sometimes we'll look at
Python code and go like this really it
looks nice right it looks nice so I like
that about Python so you still keep that
property but you get to control it in
any way you want you can actually hide
the details from non-engineers you can
actually enforce different kinds of
business rules the last line
reproducibility and machine readability
is my favorite topics and
reproducibility actually and couple and
covers a bunch of other areas that might
not be very obvious if you're actually
if you have a very advanced dsl the way
that better scribe where you're wrapping
a lot of stuff so the fact that you know
numpy scikit-learn all those users are
hidden but they're still text files
there's still Python files you can check
them in you can compare your models
using a source control version very very
easily you can reproduce if you're doing
time series for testing for example it's
one of my favorite topics ever if you're
doing time series forecasting for
example and you want to know how come I
got this result from my forecast for
months ago if your entire forecast
definition was implemented this way and
checked in a everyone else including the
business analyst who might not
necessarily know python
we'll actually get trained to understand
what it is and be you might be able to
dip it you might be able to see why the
model actually shows you different
results and the Machine readability
speaks into our plays into that thing
and it will actually it will actually
bring your arms of other benefits for
example remember was talking about the
data swarm being a dependency graph
description language kind of a thing
well since it's implemented as a DSL it
allows you to do things like this
structure it's Python but it also has
structure in it so you can actually slap
a dashboard on top of it and suddenly
you can see how those dependencies are
actually working out as I said Mike will
talk more about this stuff it's pretty
powerful you can do pretty powerful
things using parts on as your dsl and
the interesting thing is all frameworks
all API is eventually kind of you know
converge to a DSL of their own either
the way I described which is pretty cool
but you don't have to do it that way any
mature and structured API is essentially
a dsi alright so the moral of the story
is when you finally need that dsl
consider using Python itself as the
basis of dsl because it works
beautifully everyone understands how it
works and you can do very amazing things
with it all right so I'm almost done we
talked about a bunch of technical things
and I talked a lot about not directly
data science itself or machine learning
itself or natural language processing
itself but I talked a lot about the
infrastructure that's you know one of
the things that that I care about a lot
to run data science on a sound
infrastructure that Python provides us
but at the end of the day all that cool
code that actually does a lot of machine
learning stuff all the functionality
that you have that you get from guitar
poor pi PI and all that kind of things
all the C++ libraries in the world and
all the dsl's that you can design are
not going to help you you still need
people and
you cannot do it all by yourself and
this is the cool part about the whole
thing community is important and Python
actually has a pretty good community
apart on itself has been also known as a
growing and vast and very diverse
community but we have other things
there's like on Stack Overflow one of
the most popular languages and I'm not
even showing the PI data related stuff
here even without that it's actually
pretty pretty popular and there are all
kinds of physical meetups that you can
you can go to this is just around here
if you if you go and check it out you
can see that all over the country there
are different needs up a meet up that we
can go to to learn about Python itself
data signs and all kinds of nature
language processing machine learning
it's all over there finally there are
events like this pi data you know which
is a pretty cool around this is I follow
a lot of different conferences this is
by far one of the favorite conferences
that I have around this big data data
science kind of topics because it's not
what's the right way to say it it is not
too fluffy there's still cold people
still show code on screen I like that
and but it's not very deep that you
don't understand what's going on and you
have to be an expert in the topic either
so at least for me it strikes the right
balance and I like PI data and I like
having events like that that actually a
make Python community what it is today
and finally of course if you choose spy
tone for your startup on the 42 of your
startup you'll be in good company we
have a lot of folks around here that
actually like to use Python inside
Facebook all right with that I think I
actually managed to finish about 10
minutes early which is a miracle but
I'll concludes and I'll open up for
questions if you have any